do you know magnet magnet magnet
yes ma'am eat okay so a magnet on my my
fridge my icebox and then they they do
you magnet I stop working at I do
understand okay so is that because of
the machines that you're working on or
summer machinae machine ideas or motion
machine a machine this machine and blue
room oh hey hey let's see
stop stop shut up Smirnoff booty me upon
your mind she's he on the future you
hear me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you aren't gonna pay for those
[Music]
listen me that man in there
I know he doesn't look at but he is one
of the most dangerous men in the world
he's murdered many children name yet
dismay will it started
Lisa Milliken Scott's vineya yet
emotionally see about neurogenic in the
tibias fallen Savi it's gaya - alexey
the generators kudani Padilla's Patania
which torched none if targeted center
[Music]
food Nika Musa he says it's strawberry
I'm sorry his Slurpee
he says it's strawberry so what huh he
did ask for cherishing cuz I didn't have
cherry and he would like sure yeah you
tell him he can forget it
yet fishing yet took Evora yesterday in
the woods he could have escaped but he
didn't 30 seconds where it comes
knocking on that door
swoosh timer stopped his potato in your
toes near your billion discredited but
he is now naked
sorry exposed to compromise and we'll
get you to your key but haven't got bull
steer em boo
he says he likes your courage you remind
him of a fat Rambo Jessica's Ashton
medicine Yutzy sex you should have sex
in yep No
yes Tom Americans can crush the Nina
Mona Lisa Lisa kaksi de patatas are
totally basilia to delusion abit
American 'some
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the be the chimp adjustable I except for
a man for a corndog